les premiers rails du tram traits sont
arrivés à saint germain en laye il ya
maintenant un peu plus d'un mois la
pause a commencé depuis la station rer a
jusqu'à la gare de saint germain grande
ceinture des travaux prévus sur près de
quatre kilomètres durant un an
donc cette pose de voix se réaliser et
réalisé sur une plateforme béton pause
classique nous avons en premier coulage
de béton pose de rails un deuxième
coulage de béton et on viendra ensuite
une troisième étape de coulage qui
définira le niveau définitif du tramway
de plusieurs zones de travaux l'avenue
des loges l'avenue du président kennedy
ou encore la rn184 d axe très fréquenté
par les automobilistes
on peut aussi avoir des contraintes qui
sont propres projets par exemple du fait
de traverser des routes importantes
c'est le cas de la rn184 et de la rd 190
du côté de l'allée des loges ont un
impact aussi la rd 157 donc aux limites
extrêmement les impacts sur la
circulation routière
restera ensuite la pose du mobilier la
réalisation des stations avec les
premiers essais en 2021
le projet final prévoit de relier saint
germain en laye à saint cyr l'école en
passant par mareil marly et noisy le roi
un parcours de 19 km coût total de
l'infrastructure 306 millions d'euros
mise en service prévue à la fin de
l'année 2021